THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NEARLY A MONTH AFTER THE HOUSE
PASSED TWO LAME ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP, NANCY PELOSI
FINALLY, FINALLY ANNOUNCED
URGENT CASE NEEDED TO BE SLOWLY
TRANSMITTED TO THE SENATE.
>> THE
>> HHE
>> HEE
>> HE ABUSED HIS POWER AND
OBSTRUCTED A CONSTITUTIONALLY
INSTRUCTED IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
IN AMERICA, NO ONE IS ABOVE THE
LAW.
THE NEXT STEP IS SIMPLE, THE
SENATE SHOULD CONDUCT A FAIR
TRIAL.
>> Laura: HE IS NOT BIASED.
THE SLOW ROLL OF HER ARTICLES,
THAT ITSELF SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT
THESE ABSURDITIES OF THIS ENTIRE
EXERCISE.
WHEN PRESSED ABOUT WHY SHE
DECIDED TO SEND THE ARTICLES
DESPITE ZERO CONCESSIONS FROM
McCONNELL, SENIOR MEMBERS OF
HER OWN PARTY STRUGGLED TO MOVE
BEYOND GIBBERISH.
>> SHE THOUGHT VERY CAREFULLY
ABOUT THIS WITH THE CONJUNCTION
OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS.
YOU KNOW, SHE'LL MAKE HER CASE
AND PROCEED FORWARD.
>> Laura: CAN I BUY A VOWEL
PLEASE?
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER IS
CLEARLY IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT.
>> THE HOUSE MAJORITY THINKS
POLITICAL MAY HAVE STARTED THIS
WITH FRIVOLITY.
IT WILL FALL TO THE SENATE, TO
THE SENATE TO END IT WITH
SERIOUSNESS AND SOBRIETY.
>> Laura: HE IS RIGHT.
THE SENATE IS NOT BEHOLDEN TO
THE LOWER CHAMBER AND
DETERMINING TRIAL PROCEDURES.
ANYMORE THAN THEY SENATE CAN
DICTATE WITH THE HOUSE DOES.
NANCY PELOSI KNOWS THIS.
IT'S ALL A FARCE.
McCONNELL, FRANKLY HAS BEEN A
BEACON OF CLARITY FOR WEEKS.
RAISING THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS AT
EVERY TURN.
HE'S REPEATEDLY DEMONSTRATED HOW
ABSURD AND HAVE SEEN THIS ENTIRE
UKRAINE IMPEACHMENT WAS FROM THE
START.
TODAY McCONNELL GAVE THE
APPEARANCE, KIND OF HOLDING A
DOOR OPEN TO WITNESSES AT THE
SENATE TRIAL.
>> WE WILL BE DEALING WITH THE
WITNESS ISSUE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME.
I THINK IT CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE
TO POINT OUT THAT BOTH SIDES
WOULD WANT TO CALL WITNESSES
THAT THEY WOULD WANT TO HEAR
FROM.
>> Laura: YOU SEE THE TRICK
GOING ON THERE.
AS I SAID LAST NIGHT, HE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD TO THIS
NIGHTMARE.
HE COULD IN HIS OPENING
RESOLUTION TOMORROW INCLUDE A
MOTION TO DISMISS THE FRAUDULENT
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
THE FACTS, THE LAW, AND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT.
AN ACTUAL TRIAL IS ONLY
NECESSARY IF PRECEDED BY A
LEGITIMATE INDICTMENT.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN HERE.
THE PROCESS AND THE HOUSE WAS
INFECTED BY PARTISAN TANKS AND
EFFECTED LEGAL ARGUMENTS.
FIRST THE HOUSE FAILED TO MAKE
THEIR CASE UNDER APPLICABLE LAW.
THE CONSTITUTION CLEARLY STATES
A PERSON CAN ONLY BE IMPEACHED
FOR TREASON, BRIBERY, OR OTHER
HIGH CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS.
HERE NONE OF THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED.
THERE WAS NO UNDERLYING CRIME.
>> THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST
IMPEACHMENT AND HISTORY WHERE
THERE WOULD BE CONSIDERABLE
DEBATE, AND IN MY VIEW NOW
COMPELLING EVIDENCE OF THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME.
>> Laura: THE TWO ARTICLES
FILED AGAINST THE PRESIDENT ARE
DEFICIENT.
THE FIRST, ABUSE OF POWER IS
JUST TOTALLY MADE OUT.
ACCORDING TO THE RADICALS AND
THEIR PARTIES, THE PRESIDENT IS
ABUSING HIS POWER EVERY TIME HE
ENFORCES, LET'S SAY IMMIGRATION
LAW.
HE CAN'T DO THIS, HE IS ABUSING
HIS POWER, WOULD THAT COUNT AS
AN ARTICLE OF IMPEACHMENT?
IF
THE PRESIDENT ACTED SQUARELY
WITH HIS ARTICLE ONE POWERS IN
HIS TELEPHONE CONVERSATION WITH
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT SAID HE FELT
NO PRESSURE, NO QUID PRO QUO.
THIS IS WHY THE DEMOCRATS
ABANDON THEIR TALK OF THE QUID
PRO QUO AND OF COURSE ALL THE
OTHER STUFF THEY WERE THROWING
IN THE KITCHEN SINK, EXTORTION,
YOU NAME IT.
>> THERE ARE A NUMBER OF EVENTS
YOU ARE INVESTIGATING FOR WHICH
I CANNOT BRING ANY FIRST-HAND
KNOWLEDGE.
>> WHAT I CAN DO FOR YOU HERE
TODAY IS TO TELL YOU WHAT I
HEARD FROM PEOPLE.
>> YOU HAVE NO TESTIMONY TODAY
THAT TIES PRESIDENT TRUMP TO A
SCHEME TO WITHHOLD AID FROM
UKRAINE IN EXCHANGE FOR THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> OTHER THAN MY OWN
PRESUMPTION.
>> WHICH IS NOTHING!
>> Laura: THAT'S MY FAVORITE
OF ALL.
THE SECOND OF OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS IS EVEN MORE LEGITIMATE
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
NOW WE WILL IMPEACH PRESIDENTS
WHO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS TO
OBSERVE PRIVILEGES OR OTHERWISE
DEFEND THEIR EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY?
THAT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
FROM DAY ONE ADAM SCHEFTER AND
COMPANY MADE IT
CLEAR THAT THEY WOULDN'T GO TO
COURT TO ENFORCE SUBPOENAS, WHAT
DOES THAT TELL YOU.
A NO CONFIDENCE IN THEIR CASE.
THEY CLAIMED THERE WAS NO TIME.
THEY POINTED TO THE URGENCY OF
THE MATTER.
WE HAD TO STOP TRUMP, HE WAS
GOING TO DO IT AGAIN.
REMEMBER ALL THAT?
IT WAS LIKE, HURRY UP AND WAIT
FOR AN ENTIRE MONTH.
THEY'RE GOING TO ANY IMPEACHMENT
ARTICLES TO THE SENATE.
IF ANYBODY SHOULD BE CHARGED
WITH ABUSE OF POWER, IT PELOSI
AND SCHIFF.
>> IF YOU IMPEACH A PRESIDENT'S,
IF YOU MAKE A HIGH CRIME AND
MISDEMEANOR OUT OF GOING TO THE
COURTS, IT IS AN ABUSE OF POWER.
IT'S YOUR ABUSE OF POWER.
YOU ARE DOING PRECISELY WHAT
YOU'RE CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT
FOR DOING.
>> Laura: THE POLITICS OF THIS
IMPEACHMENT STINK TO HIGH HEAVEN
AND THEY ALWAYS HAVE.
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T GET A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN TO VOTE FOR IT.
NOT ONE!
THE FRAMERS MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT IMPEACHMENT HAD TO BE
BIPARTISAN TO BE LEGITIMATE.
THE UNDERLYING CONDUCT HAD TO BE
EGREGIOUS.
>> HAMILTON AND FEDERAL 65'S
HAVE THE GREATEST DANGER IS FOR
IMPEACHMENT TO TURN ON HOW MANY
VOTES ONE PARTY CAN HAVE AGAINST
THE OTHER PARTY.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
IT WOULD BE IDEAL IF WE HAD
IMPEACHMENTS THAT WERE NEUTRAL,
OBJECTED, BIPARTISAN.
IN THIS CASE IT DOESN'T RISE TO
THAT LEVEL IN ANY SENSE.
>> Laura: IT SHOULDN'T BE
TREATED AS LEGITIMATE EITHER.
DEMOCRATS USED TO AGREE THAT
IMPEACHMENT SHOULD BE DRIVEN
FULLY BY ONE PARTY.
>> WE ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE THE
REPUBLICANS AND THE HOUSE ARE
PARALYZED WITH HATRED.
UNTIL THE REPUBLICANS FREE
THEMSELVES OF THIS HATRED, OUR
COUNTRY WILL SUFFER.
>> HISTORY IS GOING TO QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS JUST A
PARTISAN LYNCHING OR WHETHER OR
NOT IT WAS SOMETHING THAT IN
FACT MET THE STANDARDS.
THE VERY HIGH BAR.
>> Laura: BY THEN, HE ACTUALLY
MEMBERS WERE HE WAS.
WHAT HAPPENED?
DONALD TRUMP HAPPENS, THAT'S
WHAT.
FINALLY IT'S TIME THAT MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS START EARNING THEIR
PAYCHECK.
WE FACE A WIDE ARRAY OF
CHALLENGES THAT NEED THE
PRESIDENT'S UNDIVIDED ATTENTION.
I RON, INFRASTRUCTURE, THE
SKYROCKETING COST OF HEALTH CARE
STILL.
THIS IS ALL A DANGEROUS
DISTRACTION McCONNELL SHOULD
CALL IT OUT AS SUCH.
MID ROMNEY AND THE OTHER FOLKS
WHO ARE WOBBLY, MITT ROMNEY HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A HERO
HERE.
I SAID HERO.
HE HAD A HANDFUL OF THE OTHER
WAVERING REPUBLICAN SENATORS
HAVE THE POWER TO PRESERVE THE
LEGITIMACY AND THE CHECK OF
IMPEACHMENT.
ALLOWING NEW WITNESSES INTO THE
PROCESS AT THIS POINT, IT ONLY
EMPOWERS THE PARTISANS THAT
BEGAN THIS MADNESS FROM THE
BEGINNING!
THE CONSTITUTIONAL DEFICIENCY IS
OBVIOUS ON ITS FACE.
I THINK ROMNEY KNOWS THAT.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THEY STOP
THE DEMOCRATIC SENATORS ITCHING
FOR A SHOW TRIAL.
ALLOWING THIS IMPEACHMENT TO GO
FORWARD ONLY SERVES TO SET A
POISONOUS PRECEDENT FOR FUTURE
COMMANDERS IN CHIEF.
LONG AFTER TRUMP IS GONE.
THIS IS A TIME FOR THE G.O.P. TO
STAND TOGETHER.
JUST LIKE THEY DID IN THE FACE
OF THE BRETT KAVANAUGH SMEARS.
LENDING ANY LEGITIMACY TO THE